hey welcome to the Reuben report i'm
dave rubin according to all these papers
in front of me and we have by far the
best show we've ever had in terms of
hair I assure you of that Shana Malcolm
YouTube superstar and Sam Roberts the
man single-handedly taking over Sirius
XM are with me and let's get right to it
all right Congress have you heard of
these clowns they are taking the month
of August off as they do every year
because you know they work so hard for
you all the time they're doing so much
good work constantly that they all
deserve the entire month off because you
get the whole month off don't you right
yeah and let's take a look at the
official website as to why they get the
whole month off by tradition and law
Congress recesses for the month of
August during the Senate's early years
members attempted to adjourn in the
spring before the summers heat and
oppressive humidity overwhelm them and
their small staff blah blah blah blah
blah and then they have to go home this
is a chance for senators to spend time
with their families meet with
constituents in their home states and
catch up on summer reading right yes
because they're so busy all the time
they never see their families their pass
on all these good laws for us and all
that great stuff yeah but basically this
was put in in action originally because
they didn't have air conditioning which
I'm pretty sure they have now so Shauna
you're laughing already is this just the
most respect anything from the
government at this point they get a
month off because of a rating of air
conditioning in 1880 it's a legitimate
problem air conditioned it's hot yeah
it's hot it is hot it NDC gets humid
that is I haven't been so I'll have to
take your word for it but um you know in
terms of is that is it deserved or
earned that's a whole other you know
argument as to whether or not two
hundred years ago it was a good idea I
totally get it two hundred years ago
yeah now not so much yeah uh there are
too many things that I think need work
in this country for it to be it oh it's
a great idea for you get a whole month
not to do that but i think the the you
know sticking with tradition this
country does love have a lot of
traditions that we you know kind of
embrace and keep in place and so is this
one of those things that we get to keep
even though it's kind of aren't
antiquated and not of much use to us
anymore and the reasoning behind it is
no longer valid so well you are slightly
back in Congress completely nuts wow I
cannot Sam yeah at what point did
grown-up start getting summer vacation
yeah like we're done with this like the
kids get summer vacation because our
they work so hard in school and every
kind of that's a joke right you know
what I mean it's like schools not that
tough until except when you're in school
then you think it is then you get out of
school and you're like that was really
easy Congress I mean it was it was
pretty easy yeah Congress taking summer
vacation it's like it's like a goof like
it doesn't it seem like it seems like
it's a movie like they should be going
to summer camp together to learn how to
play nice or something I mean I remember
with you when I first realized that if
you don't vote in Congress you just
didn't vote right he's like oh yeah he
wasn't here for that vote and said they
don't even have to go to work they don't
have they don't have to vote they don't
have to go to work half the time and
they don't they don't read the bill no
they're not doing much I can't believe
your life in Congress okay the only
thing I'll say in their defense is even
though in see this is theoretical yeah
they're not always effective at their
jobs but what they are doing their jobs
in theory they this is a difficult job
to do and so and so okay have you been
the Congress hey hey I can feel it in
Congress you know what you are good at
that you're really good at that dude
again RJ yeah you know what I changed my
whole position no hold on I want to go
go with your crazy here I'm just saying
that in theory if they are doing their
jobs this there is a lot of pressure and
if they are using the time accordingly
not the summer reading yeah I think
you're good with the summer reading is
laughter they all reading Fifty Shades
of their library get out once they have
an audiobook you can just play it in the
car on the way to work you'll be fine
but I think in theory if they are using
time to meet with constituents like it
speaks about if that if the time is
being allocated in that way to really
get in touch with the people you're
representing and making sure that those
needs are being met then in theory it's
not a bad idea but that's not actually
what's gonna happen they're gonna go to
the Hamptons they're gonna go out you
know combos and you know it's all
they're going to
come back tad and great and it's like I
thought you were afraid of AC and the
heat why you so tap well I think that's
actually legit the theory of what's
going on here versus how because the
other thing is that they needed the
month because a lot of them lived far
away from AC and they had to get on a
horse and buggy I'm pretty sure I'm
pretty sure John McCain is not riding a
horse backed Arizona so he can be yelled
at in town hall meetings right we're
living in 2013 where sometimes people
relocate for their jobs and their
families with them I think Congress is
able to pack up their family and move to
DC if they want to be near their family
a lot of congressmen don't want to be
near their family that's why they don't
move it right because their mistresses
are all in dat exactly August is a
terrible month for them if they have to
go home the poor mistresses he have
needs too yeah all right so last point
on this is there any other profession
that could get away with this kind of
stuff like is there anything else that
everybody doing it could be like yeah
we're taking the month off doesn't even
matter what might be acting actually mom
we get IATA's yeah that's true you get
you know your series's off for three
months and you get to take at least a
month of that of just I'm resting well
there you go people actors actors and
politicians exactly the same